[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم السيئه
بعاصي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذا هو المشهد الان في
العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس بعد مظاهرات
تخللتها موجهات مع قوات الامن ضمن التحرك
الاحتجاجي المندد بمقتل شاب على يد الشرطه
وهذه الصور تلدنا من امام المحكمه العليا
الامريكيه بعد قرارها المثير للجدل بانه
لم يعد بامكان الجامعات اخذ العرق في
الاعتبار كعامل صريح في قبول الطلبه وهو
ما كان يسمى بالتمييز الايجابي وتعتمده
الجامعات لمنح فرص اكبر لطلبه من الاقليات
ولمعالجه العنصريه وهذا الصور من ام درمان
في السودان الصوره من هناك بعد دخول
القوات الخاصه ساحه المعركه لتنفيذ ما
وصفته بعمليات تمشيط وتطويق لقوات الدعم
السريع هناك
والى مشعري منح حيث يواصل الحجاج رمي
الجمرات في ايام التشريق الثلاثه وهي
الايام التي تلي يوم عيد الاضحى
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
غموض بشان فاجنر وقائدها
رئيس لجنه الدفاع بالدمى يؤكد انذار
بريجوجل بخساره التمويل وايقاف مشاركه
قواته في الحرب باوكرانيا ما لم يوقع عقود
وزاره الدفاع صور اقمار صناعيه تكشف شروع
بيلاروسيا في انشاءات بقاعده عسكريه
مهجوره يشتبه في انتقال المجموعه اليها
والكرملين يرفض الرد بشان مصير الجنرال
ومصدر عسكري ينفي اعتقاله
تصاعد للاحتجاجات في فرنسا بعد مقتل مراهق
من اصول جزائريه برصاص شرطي
المواجهات واعمال الشغب تمتد من باريس الى
ليون وليل ومدن اخرى
والسلطاته تدفع باربعين الفا من رجال
الامن في انحاء البلاد القضاء يوجه تهمه
القتل العمد للشرطي المتهم ماكرون يقول
خلال اجتماع طارئ لخليه الازمه ان اعمال
العنف غير مبرره
المعارك تتجدد في العاصمه السودانيه بعد
هدنه هشه في اول ايام عيد الاضحى الجيش
يكثف غاراته على مواقع الدعم السريع
ومساعد القائد العام للجيش يعلن بدء
عمليات عسكريه للقوات الخاصه في ام درمان
لانهاء ما وصفه بالتمرد فيها وفي شمال
دارفور اتفاق محلي على وقف اطلاق النار من
قبل جميع الاطراف
تصعيد اسرائيلي جديد في الضفه الغربيه
قوات الاحتلال تقتحم بلده عوريف بنابلس
بدعوى البحث عن مطلوب تتهمه بتنفيذ عمليه
اطلاق نار وفي جنين جنود الاحتلال ينسحبون
بعد اقتحام لاطراف المدينه تخللتهم
مواجهات مع شبان فلسطينيين
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا اقدام متطرف سويدي على حرق
نسخه من المصحف الشريف في ستوكهولم في اول
ايام عيد الاضحى بتصريح من الشرطه وما تلا
الواقعه من ردود فعل عربيه ودوليه مندده
وصفت العمل بالاستفزازي والمحرض على
الكراهيه لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم
ما هي الخطوات التاليه التي ستتخذها الدول
العربيه والاسلاميه رسميا وشعبيا تجاه
السويد بعد بيانات الادانه 15% قالوا انها
ستصاعد الضغوط الديبلوماسيه
39% توقعوا ان تكون هناك مقاطعه اقتصاديه
وسياسيه وقال
46% ان هذه الدول ستكتفي بالمواقف الحاليه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
محكمه بريطانيه توجه ضربه لحكومه سونيك
برفض خطه ترحيل طالبي اللجوء الى رواندا
اذا بين موسكو ومنسك اسئله تبحث عن اجابات
بشان فاجنر وقائدها فشكل العلاقه
المستقبليه مع السلطات الروسيه ما زال
غامضا في ظل رفض المجموعه توقيع عقود مع
وزاره الدفاع في الاثناء تظهر الاقمار
الصناعيه بدء اعمال انشاء في قاعده عسكريه
بيلاروسيه مهجوره ويعتقد ان مقاتلي فاجنر
سيتمركزون فيها بعد الانتقال الى
بيلاروسيا
هذه بلده تؤسبوفيتشي في بيلاروسيا التي
تضم منشات عسكريه وساحات تدريب ومخازن
ذخيره
هذه الصور مع تاكيدات بانتقال مقاتلي
فاغنر الى الدوله الحليفه لروسيا وفق
وساطه الرئيس لوكاتشينكو بعد تمرد قائدها
يفجنبي
تضمن الاتفاق الذي اوقف تحرك فاجنر داخل
روسيا بندا اكده الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين سيعرض على مقاتلي المجموعه توقيع
عقود مع وزاره الدفاع لينضموا للحرس
الوطني
والحرس الوطني انشئ عام 2016
ويعتبر من القوات شبه العسكريه التابعه
للدوله ومن مهامه المشاركه في حمايه
النظام العام وحمايه مرافق الدوله المهمه
والمشاركه في الدفاع عن اراضي الاتحاد
الروسي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الخارجيه الروسيه قالت ان على زعماء الدول
الافريقيه اي يقرروا بانفسهم ما اذا كانوا
يريدون مواصله العمل مع مجموعه فاكنر وقال
متحدث الرئاسه الروسيه ان الدوله الروسيه
لا علاقه لها بنشاط المجموعه هناك بينما
نقلت صحيفه وولد الامريكيه ان موسكو ابلغت
الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد ان فاجنر في
سوريا لن تعمل بشكل مستقل مضيفه ان مقاتلي
فاجنر انتقلوا بالفعل الى القاعده الروسيه
في اللاذقيه
وبهذا تتحول المجموعه التي وصفت مرات
بذراع الضريبه لروسيا في الخارج الى
مجموعه مسلحه لا يمكن تقدير اعدادها بدقه
غامضه من حيث مصادر التمويل ومناطق العمل
والغطاء السياسي ليبقى الاخطر ربما ما هو
هيكل القياده التي ستعمل وفقه وهل سيكون
الحرس الوطني
بديلا لها
[موسيقى]
رئيس لجنه الدفاع بمجلس الدوما الروسي
اندري
قال ان بريجوجين ابلغ بل ابلغ بان قوات
فاجنر لن تشارك في العمليات العسكريه
باوكرانيا
وسيوقف تمويلها في حال رفضها توقيع عقودا
مع وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
قبل ايام قليله من محاوله التمرد اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع ان جميع التشكيلات التي تقوم
بمهام قتاليه يجب ان توقع عقدا معها وشرع
الجميع في تنفيذ هذا القرار وهو قرار صحيح
تماما الجميع باستثناء السيد بريجوجين
الذي ابلغ انه في هذه الحاله لن تشارك
فاجنر في العمليه العسكريه الخاصه اي انه
لن يتم تخصيص اي تمويل او موارد ماديه لها
وبالنسبه للسيد بروجين وهذا هو الشيء
الرئيسي حدث ما يلي اجتمع المال والطموحات
الغبيه والحماس وادى كل هذا معا الى
محاوله خيانه وخداع الرفاق
في هذه الاثناء نفى مصدر في وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه للجزيره الانباء عن اعتقال
الجنرال
نائب قائد العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا داعيا للتعامل مع البيانات
الرسميه فقط وقال الكريم انه ليس لديه ما
يضيفه بشان وضع نائب قائد عمليات اوكرانيا
لافتا الى ان وزاره الدفاع هي المعنيه
بهذا الامر وشدد على ان ما يهم روسيا هو
تحقيق اهداف العمليات العسكريه الخاصه
وانها ستعمل على ذلك
قال المتحدث باسم وزارات الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان عدم الاستقرار في بلد كبير
وقوه عسكريه مثل روسيا دائما ما يثير
القلق اضاف ان ما جرى الاسبوع الماضي في
روسيا ليس علامه على استقرار الدوله واكد
ان الخارجيه الامريكيه ليس لديها اي
تقييما بشان وضع بيجوجن او اي من مسؤولي
فاجنر الاخرين في بيلاروسيا او اي من
الجنرالات الروس وان الاداره تواصل مراقبه
الوضع انكسب وشدد على انه من السابق
لاوانه تحديد ما سيحدث لقوات فاجنر
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من موسكو
سرجيستروكان الباحث في المجلس الروسي
للشؤون الدوليه ومعنى من واشنطن
رئيس برنامج الامن في مركز عبر الاطلس
سنبدا معك
الكل يتساءل الان ما هو مصير فاجنر هل
لديك جواب
في الحقيقه هذا هو السؤال والاجابه عليه
بمليون دولار بعد مرور هذا الاسبوع من
الجنون في روسيا هذا السؤال هو السؤال
المطروح ولكن ما هو واضح الان هو ان
مجموعه فاجنر هي قيد اعاده التشكل لربما
او محاوله
الانتقال الى واقع جديد واقع ما بعد
بطريقه عمليه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
المقاتلين المنظمين تحت لواء فاجنر
بتوقيعي الى توقيع عقود مع وزاره الدفاع
من غير الواضح ما هو العدد الذي سوف يوقع
هذه العقود والعدد الذي يرفض توقيع هذه
العقود ولكن على اي حال مجموعه كما هي
الان لن تستمر على سبيل المثال اجزاء من
هذه المجموعه سوف تنضوي تحت لواء القوات
المسلحه الروسيه اما فيما بعد طبعا وبنسبه
الى مصير فريجوجن يقرر فيما بعد وهو جزء
من الاتفاق
بتيسير من السيد لوكيشن
ما هي توقعات الغربيه لمستقبل هذه
المجموعه خصوصا وانه وانها كما يبدو
ستتمركز في بيلاروسيا وفق الاتفاق الذي
جرى على انهاء التمرد والحديث الان عن
تاهيل قاعده عسكريه في بيلاروسيا لاستقبال
هذه المجموعه
كما قال الزميل من روسيا هناك عدد كبير من
التوقعات ولكن في حقيقه الامر ما من احد
يعرف خير معرفه ما هو مصير مجموعه فاجنر
كما قال زميلي هناك سلسله من الخيارات
هناك خيار الانضمام الى الجيش الروسي ولكن
لا اتوقع ان الجنود الروس سوف يتلقون هذه
الانباء بطريقه ايجابيه بالنسبه الى خيار
العوده الى روسيا والى عائلاتهم واحبائهم
هذا خيار وايضا هناك خيار الانضمام الى
بريجوجن في هذه القاعده العسكريه السابقه
التي اشرتم اليها في بيلاروسيا
تشانكو اتاح هذه القاعده
المقاتل المقاتلون يمكنهم ان ينضموا الى
بيجوجن في بيلاروسيا
هنا يمكننا ان نعود الى قرارات ذلك يتعين
علينا ان ننتظر لنرى دور قوات فاجنر في
اوروبا واين ينتهي بهم المطاف ولكن كما
اشار الزميل من روسيا ايضا هناك مجموعات
في افريقيا في الشرق الاوسط في سوريا
وبالتالي بنسبه الى القياده وتسلسل وهرميه
القياده تبقى مجهوله وبالتالي هناك الكثير
من الغموض ويتعين علينا ان ننتظر لنرى
تجليات الامور هنا سؤال عن القياده نذهب
به الى سيد سروكان رئيس لجنه الدفاع في
الدومه سيد سيرجي يقول انه سيتم حرمان
التمويل لكل من لا يوقع العقود مع وزاره
الدفاع وبريكوجين لم يوقع العقد مع وزاره
الدفاع هل يسري ذلك اذا عدم التمويل هل
يسري عليه في هذه الحاله ام يسري على كل
المجموعه التي ذهبت الى بي لاروسيا
ايضا
هذه مرحله جديده في القصه
برمتها دعونا نفكر بالقصه من اولها
فاقنر كانت شركه خاصه ويفترض انها شركه
خاصه ولكن هنا يطرح السؤال بنسبه الى
التمويل طبعا كان رجل اعمال ناجح ولكن
اكتشفنا بعد مرور الايام ان مجموعه فاقدر
كانت تتلقى كميات كبيره من الاموال من
الدوله
الروسيه وهو امر يصعب ان نفهمه كيف
لمجموعه خاصه او شركه خاصه ان تمول من
ميزانيه الدوله على الارجح السبب هو
فاعليه مجموعه فاجنر المرتفعه في المراحل
الاولى من العمليه العسكريه ويجب ان نقرب
ادى دورا اساسيا في
السيطره على المدينه الاستراتيجيه بخموت
واماكن اخرى وبالتالي اود ان اقول انه في
بدايه
العمليه العسكريه انخرطت مجموعه فاجنر في
قتال قوي ودارا وساعدت القوات المسلحه
الروسيه ولكن صحيح اننا نتحدث عن وضع غير
طبيعي جيش داخل الجيش ودوله داخل الدوله
هو وضع غير طبيعي
ان
حاول ان يواجه الدوله ويتحدث سلطه الدوله
وما من دوله تقبل ذلك انسوا روسيا فكروا
باي بلد غربي او اي بلد في منطقه اسيا ما
من دوله تسمح بوضع مماثل شخصا يمثل شركه
خاصه يحاول ان يملي على وزاره الدفاع ما
الذي تقوم به وما الذي لا تقوم به
قلت علينا ان ننتظر لنرى ما دور الذي
سيكون
ليفاغنر في اوروبا وسائر الانحاء
بالنظر الى المخاوف التي يتم التعبير عنها
في بعض الدول الغربيه هل سيجري الانتظار
ام انه سيكون هناك تحرك ربما استباقي تجاه
هذه المجموعه خصوصا وان انها اتهمت في
السابق بالقيام بادوار تخريبيه في اكثر من
منطقه
في الحقيقه اعتقد انه بالنسبه الى الدول
الغربيه اود ان اوضح كل النقاط المرتبطه
بسؤالك الولايات المتحده الامريكيه والدول
الغربيه الاخرى تراقب عن كثب ما يحصل في
روسيا وما يحصل مع مجموعه
وتامل احلال الاستقرار في روسيا امام احد
يود ان يرى الفوضى منتشره في روسيا
وبالتالي الغرب لن يقوم باي شيء فقط يراقب
الدول الغربيه تراقب وتتاكد من ان شركه
افاجنر لا تشكل مصدر تهديد للغرب وهو ما
هو الحال عليه هي لا تشكل تهديدا الان
بالنسبه الى الوضع في روسيا والوضع في
اوكرانيا اعتقد ان مجموعه هي قيد التخلي
عن الاسلحه الثقيله بالنسبه الى القوات
المسلحه الروسيه او بالنسبه الى الحرس
الوطني لا اعرف عدد المقاتلين الذين
انضموا الى الوكالات الرسميه والمقاتلين
الذين بقوا مع بريجوجن ايضا هناك مساله
التمويل هو بحاجه الى التمويل لكي يحافظ
على جيشا صغير له او يكن له الولاء في
بيلاروسيا ولكن في هذه المرحله اعتقد ان
بريجوجن هو شخصيه ضعيفه هو يحظى بشعبيه
ولكن على المستوى العسكري هو ضعيف شكرا
رئيس برنامج الامثله مركز عبر الاطلسي من
واشنطن وشكرا
استروكان
بحث المجلس الروسي لشؤون الدوليه ضيفه من
موسكو
[موسيقى]
الى فرنسا حيث اندلعت مواجهات بين قوات
الامن والشبان خلال مسيره اطلق بل اطلق
عليها منظمها اسم المسيره البيضاء في
ضاحيه بباريس احتجاجا على مقتل مراهق من
اصول جزائريه على يد شرطي وقد اعلنت
السلطات توقف خدمات ترامب والحافلات
المسائيه في العاصمه خوفا مما سمته اعمال
التخريب بينما توسع نطاق اعمال الشغب الى
ليون ومدن اخرى وقد وجه الادعاء تهمه
القتل العمد للشرطي في حين قال ماكرون
خلال اجتماع طارئ لخليه الازمه ان اعمال
العنف غير مبرره
ليله اخرى من ليالي الغضب في فرنسا
تحولت فيها عدد من مدن الطواحي الى ساحه
مواجهات بين الشرطه وشبان الغاضبين
[تصفيق]
ساعات من الكر والفر قبل ان يسفر الصباح
عن مشاهد مثل هذه
بدا واضحا ان التوتر قد وصل مداعه بعد
مقتل نايل الشاب ب 17 عاما بسلاح الشرطي
فقد اعلن ما يشبه حاله الطوارئ السياسيه
في البلد فلا تحركات للوزراء ولا انشطه
خارج هذا الملف
اما الرئيس فقد عقد مجلس امن قومي مصغر
راى فيه الا شيء يبرر اعمال العنف ودعا
الى التهدئه
الساعات الاخيره ابتسمت بمشاهد عنف ضد
اقسام الشرطه وايضا ضد مدارس وبلديات
وبالتالي بشكل اساسي ضد مؤسسات الجمهوريه
وهذا امر لا يمكن تبريره بالنسبه لي يجب
ان تؤدي الساعات المقبله الى التامل
والاحترام والمسيره البيضاء يجب ان تتم
تحت هذا العنوان
تمت المسيره بالفعل لكن تحت عنوان الغضب
الاف خرجوا في ممطير للتنديد بمقتل نايل
لكن لا غضب يعادل غضب الامهات تداريه
امنايل بشعارات تدعو الى تحقيق العداله
[موسيقى]
لكن ذلك على اهميته لم يكن السبب الوحيد
لخروج المتظاهرين
انايس ام لطفلين لا ترغب في تكرار هذه
الماساه انا ام لدي ولدا ولا اريد ان يقتل
بسبب مخالفه بسيطه مثل رفض التفتيش
العداله يجب ان تتحقق ولكن هناك حاجه ايضا
لاصلاح كبير للشرطه في هذه المسيره تذكير
بان مقتل نايل ليس معزولا عن سياقه
الاجتماعي
والسياسي بل تاكيد على ان العلاقه بين
فرنسا وضواحيها ليست بخير تماما وان العنف
البوليسيه ليس سوى وجه من اوجه ازمه مركبه
تتداخل فيها تعقيدات التاريخ
وحسابات سياسه
وحسابات السياسه ذاتها تقول ان هذه الازمه
غدت مفتوحه على كل المخاطر
[موسيقى]
فالذاكره الفرنسيه تحفل باحداث مثيره عام
2005 انضلعت ايضا بسبب مقتل شابين على يد
عناصر الشرطه لذلك بدات تعامل القضائي
صارما فقد قدم الشرطي للمحاكمه بتهمه
القتل العمد لترتفع لائحه افراد الشرطه
الذين حكموا بجرائم مماثله منذ عام 2022
الى سته
هكذا تجد فرنسا نفسها من جديد في مواجهه
تؤكد ان شيئا ما قد انكسر بالفعل في
العلاقه بين الشرطه وشبان الضواحي
محمد البقالي الجزيره
طبعا مشاهدينا مراسل الجزيره يفيدنا بوقوع
صدمات وادرامي نار ومناوشات عدد من المدن
الفرنسيه وقد ينضم الينا لاحقا في سياق
هذا الحصاد ولكن الان ينضم الينا من باريس
الدكتور فيصل ازدارا الباحث في علم
الاجتماع السياسي دكتور فيصل كيف يمكن
تقييم رده فعل الشارع رغم الشجب لهذه
الجريمه على لسان رئيس الجمهوريه
والمسؤولين
واحاله الشرطي بتهمه القتل العمد
في حقيقه الامر
تصريح رئيس الجمهوريه البارحه
بالدعوه الى التهدئه كانت كخطوه استباقيه
لما قد يحدث وقد حدث ما كان في الحسبان
الشارع يعني
الانزلاق يعني
المظاهرات واعمال الشعب والعنف اخذت منحى
اكبر وهذا ما تخوفت منه السلطات الحكوميه
ولكن نرى ان اليوم بعد
الاجتماع ما بين الاجتماع الوزاري الذي
تراسه رئيس الجمهوريه الماكرون
نرى ان هناك تغير في الخطاب
بعدما كان خطاب تهدئه
وترحم على الشاب الذي
الضحيه
فتغير الخطاب الى خطاب
الصرامه في التعامل مع العنف ومع الذين
يثيرون الشغب في الضواحي المدن الكبرى في
في فرنسا طيب ولكن السؤال لماذا اتت رده
الفعل على هذا الشكل
الواسع والكبير في عدد كبير من المدن
اعمال شغب وادررام نار رغم كما ذكرت لك
الخطاب الاول
بشجب الجريمه واحاله الشرطي الى القضاء
اولا لانه الوضع الاجتماعي هش
جراء الاحتجاجات بعد اقرار قانون التقاعد
لدينا حركه السترات الصفراء انخراط
المنظمات البيئيه
وكان الوضع
يه
لتاجيك الوضع اكثر لهذا قلت انه رئيس
الجمهوريه حاول في
مبادره استباقيه للدعوه الى التهدئه لان
لانه يعرف اننا لسنا يعني
لمرحله
بؤره توتر جديده طبعا هناك ايضا
تصاعد موجه العنف الشرطي واستفاف الحكومه
وراء المؤسسات الامنيه فيما قبل
كما نعرف ان رئيس الجمهوريه اقر قانون ما
يسمى بقانون
المدعم للسياسه للامن الداخلي الذي تم
اقراره في اول
اكتوبر من
2017 اين يعطي ضمانات وحريه اكبر لاعوان
الانف في استعمال السلاح
والان يعني هذا الموضوع مطروح بحده هناك
دعوات
للمطالبه باعاده النظر في هذا القانون
الان الدكتور فيصل قبل ان نخدم معك تحدثت
عن ان هناك الان تحول في الخطاب الرسمي
نحو الصرامه اكثر في التعامل مع هذه
الاحتجاجات بالتوازي هناك انتشار واسع
للشرطه في الشارع ما المتوقع باختصار لو
سمحت
قد تنذر الاوضاع بتصعيد اخي اكثر لان
الارضيه مهيئه لذلك كما سبق سبق وان ذكرت
علما ان
الحكومه وعلى راس رئيس الجمهوريه
يحاول دائما ان يثبت فكره انه يجب افساح
المجال للعداله بالقيام
بعملها لان العداله هي الوحيده القادره
لارجاع الحقوق لاصحابها
وما شخصيا ما اندد به ونرى انه يعني
يصب الزيت في على النار هو تباين المواقف
في خلال الطبقه السياسيه حتى في الاسره
السياسيه الواحده نرى هناك تباين في
المواقف بين من يؤيد هذه
يعني
دكتور فيصل ازدارا البحث في علم الاجتماع
السياسي ضيفنا من باريس شكرا جزيلا لك
الى نونتير ومن هناك ينضم الينا مراسل
الجزيره لطفي المسعودي لطفي نقترب معك
اكثر من المشهد وكيف يتطور الموقف على
الارض
نعم منذ دقائق انسحب رجال الشرطه في هذا
الشارع خلفي وهو شارع يؤدي الى حي بابلو
بيكاسو الذي شهد اعمال عنف كبيره ليله امس
والليله السابقه لها حيث يتوقع كذلك يتجدد
اعمال العنف هذه الليله نحن نقف امام فرعا
بنكيا تم احراقه وتكسير واجهته ومنذ قليل
انتهت يعني انتهى رجال الدفاع المدني من
اخماد الحريق الذي نشب في هذا الفرع
البنكي والذي امتد حتى الى الطوابق الاولى
من البنايه السكنيه التي يوجد فيها هذا
فضلا عن عدد كبير من الواجهات للمحلات
الواجهات الزجاجيه التي تم تكسيرها وكذلك
في هذا الشارع الذي يؤدي كما قلنا الى حي
بابلو بيكاسو الشعبي تم احراق عدد من
الحدائق العامه
في
الاشجار وكذلك قلب وتكسير الاسس كما تم
احراق عدد من شروفات
المطاعم احراقها بالكامل وتكسير عدد كبير
من واجهات
المغازات مغازات بيع المواد
الغذائيه اذا كما قلنا اربعين الف شرطي تم
تجنيدهم هذه الليله تحسبا لاي اعمال شغب
وتحسبا لتجدد اعمال شخب في ضحيه نونتير
وحسب مصادر من الشرطه 19 شخصا تم اعتقالهم
اليوم في باريس وضواحيها 15 شخصا منهم من
نونتير تحديدا هنا حيث يتجند رجال الشرطه
تحسبا لتجدد اعمال الشغب وخاصه في حي
بابلو بيكاسو الشعبي كما قلت شكرا لك من
ضحيه نونتير غرب باريس مراسلنا لطفي
المسعودي
لجوء الفرنسيين بشكل متكرر ولافت الى
الشارع في الاشكالات السياسيه والاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه وما يثيره من اسئله عن دور
مؤسسات الدوله وثقه المواطنين فيها سيكون
محور نقاش لنا في فقره في المتابعه بعد
قليل
الى السودان حيث تجددت المعارك بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع لتنتهي بذلك
هدنه هشه اعلنها الطرفان بشكل منفصل
تزامنا مع عيد الاضحى وقد اعلن عضو مجلس
السياده ومساعد القائد العام للجيش ياسر
العطا اعلن بدء عمليات عسكريه للقوات
الخاصه في ام درمان لانهاء ما وصفه
بالتمرد فيها على ان تنتقل الى مناطق اخرى
في العاصمه
انتهت هدنه العيد الهشه قبل انتهائه وعاد
صوت البنادق والمدافع يخيم على المشهد في
الخرطوم القصف والرد عليه كان السمه
الابرز لمعارك العاصمه فقد قصفت طائره
الجيش مواقع للدعم السريع شرقي الخرطوم
واستمر تحليقه سيارات الاستطلاع التابعه
له جهه وذهابه ايضا قصفت مدفعيه الجيش
تجمعات للدعم السريع شرق القياده العامه
وباسلحه ثقيله كان رد قوات الدعم السريع
اذا لا هدنه مستمره ولا حسم ينهي القتال
لكن الجيش السوداني وعبر القوات الخاصه
اعلن عزمه على انهاء ما وصفه بالتمرد في
ام درمان احدى مدن العاصمه الثلاث واكبرها
ثم نقل العمليات العسكريه لبقيه المدن
وانهاء وجود قوات الدعم السريع فيها
هذا الاعلان يبقى رهينما يجري في الميدان
بالنظر لاشهر من القتال استمرت فيها معارك
العاصمه للسيطره على القصر الرئاسي ومقر
القياده العامه وحي المطار وبقيه الاحياء
السكنيه دون ان يحسم طرف النتيجه لصالحه
خارج الخرطوم يوقف اطلاق النار وفقا
لاعلان والي شمال دارفور غرب البلاد
الاتفاق كان بين حكومه الولايه وادارات
اهليه وبمشاركه جميع الاطراف يقول الوالي
ان مدينه الفاشر عادت اليها اشكال الحياه
الطبيعيه وان مساعي التدجي لتطبيق تجربه
وقف اطلاق النار في جميع مناطق اقليم
دارفور لكن اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار هذا لم
يصمد سوى ساعات اذ بدات اشتباكات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
بالاسلحه الثقيله
اكد وزير الخارجيه خلال اجتماع مع نائب
رئيس مجلس السياده بالسودان مالك عقار اكد
على الحاجه لاتخاذ التدابير لانهاء
الاعمال العدائيه في السودان وجاء في بيان
صادر عن الخارجيه الروسيه ان موسكو مستعده
في المساعده للتوصل الى تسويه للاوضاع في
المقابل قال عقار ان لافروف اعلن تضامن
موسكو مع السودان ومؤسساته الشرعيه
القائمه وعن استعداد روسيا لدعم الشعب
السوداني وعن تاكيدها على ان الحل بايدي
سودانيين انفسهم
ينضم الينا في الاستوديو الدكتور اسامه
عيدروس الاكاديمي السوداني المتخصص في
الشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه مرحبا بك دكتور
اسامه اذا دخول قوات العمليات الخاصه الان
الى الميدان وفق ما ذكر ياسر العطا كيف
سيبدل من الاوضاع
دعيني ارجع الى الوراء قليلا بس لن اخذ
ضمن قوات الدعم السريع ارتكبت ثلاث اخطاء
استراتيجيه قاتله خلال هذه العمليات اول
شيء انه عندما ضربت المقرات الثابته للدعم
السريع او تم احتلالها من قبل الجيش
انتشروا انتشار واسع في الخرطوم هذا
الانتشار كان بين في المرافق الصحيه في
المرافق في في المستشفيات في
مرافق الكهرباء والمياه وفي بيوت
المواطنين وتبع ذلك عمليه تهجير واسعه
للمواطنين في الخرطوم هذه الخطا
الاستراتيجي هنا انه اضعف بودره قوات
الدعم السريع على تجميع قواتها لانه هي
اصلا تقوم يعني استراتيجيتها على ما يسمى
بالفزع ان تجمع اكبر قدر من المقاتلين
بسرعه جدا يتحركوا ويناوروا بسرعه جدا
ولهم كثافه نيران كبيره ويحقق نتائج سريعه
جدا بذلك فعندما انتشروا في الخرطوم 23
كيلو متر مربع فقدوا هذه الخاصيه خاصيه
القدره على التجميع في نفس الوقت الخطا
الثاني انهم اخرجوا السكان من
بيوتهم تهجير قصري لسكان في الخرطوم
وفتحوا هذه البيوت للنعم من جنودهم او من
اخرين
هذا شجع اخرين من خارج الخرطوم للدخول لان
كثير من جنودهم هربوا بالغنائم وذهبوا
واتوا مع اخرين او اتى اخرين بدلهم هذا
الشيء اضعف ما يسمى في العسكريه
والربط داخل قوات الدعم السريع اي تحولت
من قوه عسكريه نظاميه تقاتل بشكل نظامي
الخطا الثالث انها عندما شعرت بانها لا
تستطيع تحقيق لانه فقدت القدره على الفزع
او جمع قواتها فقدت الضبط والربط واصبحت
قواتها غير نظاميه ولا يمكن السيطره عليها
فقامت بعمليه يعني ربما تكون ذكيه جدا او
غبيه جدا هي تجميع كل قواتها في جنوب
الخرطوم للاستفاده من بعض النجاحات التي
حققتها في معسكر اليرموك ومعسكر
الاستراتيجيه وهجمت على الاحتياط المركزي
بقوه كبيره جدا
واستطاعت اسقاط الاحتياط المركزي هذا
النجاح الكبير حقيقه سبب احباط كبير لدى
المواطن السوداني وبدا يتساءل اين الجيش
الدعم السريع رغم انه استطاع ان يسقط
الاحتياط المركزي لكن الاحتياطي المركزي
ليس واحدا من معسكرات الجيش الكبيره هو
معسكر للشرطه في مكان حاكم الفائده الاهم
منه انه يفتح الطريق الى المدرعات وفشلوا
في ان يطوروا هذا النجاح الى هجوم على
المدرعات واعود الى سؤالي دكتور الان هناك
حديث عن انتشار قوات العمليات الخاصه
التابعه للجيش يقول السيد العطاء انها
ستنهي التمرد هل هي بالفعل قادره على
تحقيق ذلك دعيني اقول انا كاكاديمي انه
فقدت قوات الدعم السريع
الفرصه لاستثمار نجاحها وتركت المبادره في
يد الجيش استطاع الجيش الان ان يتقدم
بمبادره للحراك على الارض القوات الخاصه
تقوم بشيء مهم جدا الاول منه انه تضرب
الاسلحه النوعيه
ومخازن السلاح وهذا الذي يفسر يعني
النيران العاليه والاصوات الضخمه التي
سمعت بكل ذلك كل ذلك التي تحدثت به دكتور
لم يكن متاحا في الشهرين الماضيين الان
هناك ظروف تبدلت الذي تبدل ان الجيش يعني
قوات الدعم السريع بسحبها لقواتها بشكل
كبير منهم درمان والخرطوم والخرطوم بحري
لتقوم بعمليات في جنوب الخرطوم شكرا فتحت
الباب للقوات الخاصه ان تنزل الميدان
وتعمل يعني عمل نوعي جدا سيغير من نتيجه
المعارك في رؤوس الاكاديميه السودانيه
المتخصص في الشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه
ضيفنا هنا
في يوم اخر من التصعيد الاسرائيلي بالضفه
الغربيه حاصلت وداهمت قوات الاحتلال بيت
مطلوب لديها في عريس جنوب نابلس واقتادت
والده وشقيقه للتحقيق معهما وتزعم سلطات
الاحتلال ان المطلوب نفذ عمليه اطلاق نار
قبل ايام كما اقتحم الجيش الاسرائيلي
اطراف جنين قبل الانسحاب منها تاتي هذه
التطورات بعد ايام من موافقه الحكومه
الائتلافيه المتطرفه على بناء مستوطنات
جديده في الضفه
الضفه الغربيه المحتله بين عنف الجيش
الاسرائيلي والمستوطنين وسياسات حكومه
ائتلافيه متطرفه ماذا بعد سرق جنود
الاحتلال فرحه العيد من كثير من
الفلسطينيين في ثاني ايام الاضحى المبارك
تعزيزات عسكريه ودهم واعتقالات في عريف
جنوب نابلس بزعم البحث عن مطلوب لديهم
اقتحموا بيوتا مستخدمين القنابل الصوتيه
المتفجره واقتاد والد المطلوب عبد الله
وشقيقه الى مركز الشرطه للتحقيق معهما وهم
يغادرون عريف بعدما قبضوا مضاجع بيوت
فلسطينيين غير امنين داخل منازلهم كانت
تعزيزات امنيه اسرائيليه تتجه الى جنين
اقتحمت اطراف المدينه ودوت صافرات الانذار
فيها بينما كانت المسيرات تحلق في سماء
المنطقه
الضفه لم تتعافى بعد من الجرائم التي
ارتكبها قبل ايام مستوطنون متطرفون في
بلدات وقرى فلسطينيه الادانات الداخليه
والخارجيه لتلك الاعمال الهمجيه من حرق
وتخريب لتقلل من مسؤوليه سلطات تل ابيب في
مجرى والدعوه الى عدم تاجيج التوتر سواء
من نيويورك او واشنطن لن تغير شيئا في
حقيقه تورط الاحتلال في دوامه العنف
الاخير التي تتصق تماما مع قناعات اعضاء
الحكومه الحاليه اليس ذلك جزءا من مخطط
قديم جديد اسمه توسيع المستوطنات رغم انف
الاداره الامريكيه حكومه نتنياهو وافقت
الاثنين الماضي واستغض بالحلفاء والخصوم
الدوليين على بناء خمسه الاف وسبعمائه
وحده سكنيه اضافيه لمستوطنين في الضفه
الغربيه منذ يناير الماضي وفق الائتلاف
على بناء اكثر من سبعه الاف وحده سكنيه
في عمق الضفه قررت تل ابيب الهادفه الى
اجهاض قيام دوله فلسطينيه عاصمتها القدس
الشرقيه لا تتوقف وتتنوعوا مع مرور الوقت
اخر تسريب نتنياهو لم يكن مفاجئا بالنسبه
لمن يعيشون يوميا انتهاكات الاحتلال
واختيال كل فرص السلام حتى لو كان مرا او
منقصا تحدث في اجتماع مغلق للجنه الخارجيه
والامن التابعه للكنيست عن ضروره العمل
على اشتثاس فكره اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه
مضيفا ان اسرائيل تريد بقاء السلطه
الفلسطينيه ولكنها غير معنيه بانهيارها
تهويد الضفه الغربيه وترهيب الفلسطينيين
ثنائيه الحكومه الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه
مهما اختلفت مسمياتها وتصنيفاتها الحزبيه
والمواقف الغربيه المنتقده للاستيطان
والداعيه الى ضروره احياء مفاوضات السلام
المنكوبه مجر د كلام
اصدرت محكمه الاستئناف في لندن حكما يقضي
بان خطه الحكومه البريطانيه لترحيل
اللاجئين الى رواندا مخالفه للقانون وعربت
الحكومه البريطانيه عن خيبه املها من
الحكم واكدت عزمها الطعن بينما رحبت
مفوضيه اللاجئين التابعه للامم المتحده
بقرار المحكمه
رواندا ليست بلدا امنا وخطه الحكومه
لترحيل طالب اللجوء اليها غير قانونيه حكم
قوضت به محكمه الاستئناف ابرز خطط الحكومه
البريطانيه لخفض اعداد المهاجرين غير
النظاميين حكم جاء بعد سبعه اشهر من حكم
اخر للمحكمه العليا ايد خطط الحكومه وجاء
ليرجح الكفه لصالح اللاجئين والجمعيات
الحقوقيه المسانده لهم
قرار جيد لصالح اللاجئين
بس مو بس ليس كافي لان هذه السياسه لا
انسانيه من قبل
الحكومه البريطانيه هذه الاتفاقيه مع
الحكم الرواندا لازم توقف فورا
الحكومه البريطانيه لم تخفي امتعاظها من
الحكم واكد التمسكها بسياستها في مجال
الهجره واللجوء
هذا حكم مخيب للامال وسنسعى للحصول على
اذن لاستئنافه
وقف الهجره غير النظاميه واحد من خمسه
تعهدات رئيسيه قدمها ريشيسوناك للشعب
البريطاني بعد توليه رئاسه الحكومه ولا
يبدو ان خططه للوفاء بهذا التعهد ستنجح
على الاقل حتى الان
الامور القضائيه تاخذ وقتا ونعلم ان هناك
انتخابات عامه العمل قادم ويمكن ان تعلق
هذه القضيه في المحاكم حتى موعد
الانتخابات تخطى عدد طلبات اللجوء
المتاخره لدى الحكومه 160 الفا بينما تبلغ
كلفه ايواء طالب اللجوء في الفنادق نحو
سته ملايين جنيه استرليني يوميا معضله
يشكل حلها احد اهم اولويات المواطنين
البريطانيين وفق احداث استطلاعات الراي
جوله اخرى من جولات الصراع على خطط
الحكومه البريطانيه ترحيل طالبي اللجوء
الى رواندا جوله خسرتها الحكومه ورغم
اعلانها نيتها تصيد الصراع الى اعلى
مراحله القضائيه وتلك محكمه النقب فان على
الحكومه ان تقدم اولا ما يكفي من اسانيد
قانونيه لاقناع المحكمه بالنظر في القضيه
اسعد الله الصاوي الجزيره لندن
ينضم الينا من لندن الدكتور ويليام شبس
الخبير في القانون الدولي والرئيس السابق
للجنه الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان دكتور
ويليام دلالات التي ينطوي عليها هذا
القرار من محكمه الاستئناف
في الحقيقه هذا القرار هو تراجع كبير
لسياسه الحكومه البريطانيه
وخطه الحكومه البريطانيه التي ادانتها
منظمات حقوق الانسان هذا القرار القرار
سوف يؤثر على عدد صغير ومحدود من الناس مع
ان مستويات الهجره ومعدلات الهجره نحو
المملكه المتحده هي مرتفعه للغايه اذا هو
يعكس القرارات الحكوميه هذه التدابير
الحكوميه الاله الى منع الناس من الهجره
الى المملكه المتحده بطريقه غير قانونيه
نتحدث هنا عن القوارب التي تعبر القناه
الانجليزيه من فرنسا ومن اماكن اخرى لكن
الحكومه لن تتراجع عن سياستها باعتراف
رئيسها ووزيره الداخليه وتنوي الطعن ما
فرص
تحقيق ان تكسب القضيه في هذه المرحله
نعم يمكن ان تستانف الحكومه هذا القرار
واشاروا كما تفضلتي انهم سوف يقومون بذلك
وينتقلون الى المحكمه العليا اذا القرار
على مستوى محكمه الاستئناف
بقرار قاضيين من اصل من اصل ثلاثه قضاه
اذا هذا ما ادى الى الوصول الى القرار
الحالي وبالتالي يتعين علينا ان ننتظر
لنرى نتيجه في المحكمه العليا الحكومه
تتعرض لضغوط
لحل هذه المساله
الاشكاليه قبل الانتخابات المقبله وهي سوف
تحصل بعد سنه من الزمن سوف يتطلب الامر
وقتا كي تصل الاجراءات الى مستوى
المحكمه العليا وايضا هناك محكمه حقوق
الانسان على مستوى الاو
وهي تشارك في هذه القضايا وتنتهي القضايا
عاده على مستوى الاوروبي لكن بغض النظر عن
الامور القضائيه واضحه ان هناك سياسه
معلنه من جانب الحكومه لن تقبل بالاجئين
غير النظاميين ما الذي يمكن ان تقوم به
هذه السلطات
لتنفيذ السياسه في ظل هكذا احكام قضائيه
ما يمكن ان تقوم به الوكالات الحكوميه هو
ما قامت به الحكومه البريطانيه منذ فتره
وحتى يومنا هذا اذا ما وصل الناس الى
الاراضي البريطانيه سواء كان الوصول
بطريقه قانونيه او غير قانونيه يمرون عبر
هذه الاجراءات
لكي تعرف السلطات ما اذا كان يحق للواصلين
والوافدين ان يقولوا انهم يطلبون اللجوء
بسبب الظروف الموجوده في بلاده المملكه
المتحده تقوم بتجربه
الخطه بالنسبه الى طالبي اللجوء طبعا
الطلب قد يقبل وقد يرفض اذن
الابتعاد الاف الكيلومترات عن المملكه
المتحده يؤدي الى منع الناس الاخرين من
محاوله الوصول الى المملكه المتحده بطريقه
غير قانونيه
الدولي والرئيس السابق للجنه الامم
المتحده لحقوق الانسان ضيفنا من لندن
يوصل حجاج بيت الله الحرام في مشعري منى
بمكه المكرمه رمي الجمرات في ايام التشريق
الثلاثه وهي الايام التي تالي يوم عيد
الاضحى وفيها يتوجه الحجاج كل يوم الى
منطقه الجمرات ويرمون الجمرات الثلاث
الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله
اكبر
[موسيقى]
لا لبيك الله ايام التشريق هي الايام
الثلاثه التي تلي عيد الاضحى وتبدا في
الحادي عشر من ذي الحجه خلال ليالي ايام
التشريق الثلاثه يبيت الحجاج في منى ويجوز
للمتعجل ان يغادرها في اليوم الثاني عشر
قبل غروب الشمس وفي كل يوم من ايام
التشريق يرمي الحاج الجمرات الثلاث الصغرى
والوسطى والكبرى وفي كل واحده يرمي الحاج
سبعه حصيات متعاقبه ويقف للدعاء بعد رمي
الجمره الصغرى والوسطى
وفي ثالث ايام التشريق وبعد الانتهاء من
رمي الجمرات يتوجه الحاج الى المسجد
الحرام لاداء سبعه اشواط هي طواف الوداع
الذي يعتبر اخر اعمال الحج
[موسيقى]
بالعوده الى الاحتجاجات في فرنسا التي
تاتي في سياق اضرابات واضطرابات اجتماعيه
متزايده شهدتها فرنسا على مدى سنوات
الماضيه القاسم المشترك في هذه الاحتياجات
كان نزول الفرنسيين للتظاهر في الشارع
باعداد كبيره في مؤشر على ازمه ثقه تتفاقم
بين مؤسسات الدوله والفرنسيين في العام
2018 خرجت حركه السترات الصفراء للتنديد
بارتفاع اسعار الوقود وتكاليف المعيشه لكن
سرعان ممتدت مطالبها لتشمل اسقاط
الاصلاحات الضريبيه التي سنتها الحكومه
وتطورت فيما بعد لتصل الى المداداء
باستقاله ماكرون الاحتجاجات اتخذت مسارا
تصاعديا منذ ان قرر ماكرون تمرير سن رفع
سن التقاعد او تمريره قانون رفع سن
التقاعد من 62 الى 64 استنادا على ماده
دستوريه بعد ان اخفق في تمريره برلمانيا
ومنذ ذلك الحين شهدت البلاد عده احتجاجات
واضرابات في قطاعات حيويه ابرزها النقل
العام والطيران والقطاع الصحي والخدمات
العامه الاحتجاجات الحاليه اشتعلت بعد نشر
مقطع فيديو يظهر تعمد فليظهر تعمد شرطي
قتل شاب وهو ما اثار اسئله شعبيه بشان
التعامل السلطات والمؤسسات القانونيه مع
حوادث مشابهه سابقه فهذا ثالث حادث اطلاق
نار يسفر عن سقوط قتل اثناء توقيف
السيارات في فرنسا منذ بدايه العام الجاري
وجاء في احصاء انه في العام الماضي سجلت
13 حاله وفاه نتيجه رفض الامتثال لنقاط
التفتيش المروريه تضيف الوكاله ان اغلبيه
الضحايا منذ عام 2017 كانوا من السود او
من اصول عربيه وفتح محقق الشكاوى الخاصه
بحقوق الانسان في فرنسا تحقيقا في الوفاه
هو سادس تحقيق من نوعه في حوادث مماثله في
عامي 2022
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من باريس
ايفو
عضو مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي السابق مرحبا بك
سيد ايف لماذا كل هذا اللجوء الى الشارع
في فرنسا عن ماذا يؤشر
في الحقيقه يتعينوا علينا ان نفهم ان في
فرنسا تاريخ
طويل من المظاهرات والتعبير عن وجهات
النظر نحن نتحدث عن بلد يعبر فيه الناس عن
ارائهم منذ فتره طويله ولكن صحيح منذ وصول
الرئيس ماكرون الى سده الرئاسه شاهدنا في
كل سنه مظاهرات كبيره كما اشرتم الى
السترات الصفراء وبعد ذلك مساله سن
التقاعد ومن ثم ازمه كورونا والاغلاقات
وبعد ذلك عدنا الى مساله التقاعد والان
وصلنا الى مظاهرات محدده عرفناها في العام
2005 و2006 في وجه الرئيس
نحن نتحدث عن ثوره في ضواحي المدن في
مناطق تعتبر من الم الاقل حظوه او المناطق
الفقيره التي فيها معدلات كبيره من الهجره
ولكن بالنسبه الى الارقام التي لدينا تشير
الى نوع او شكلا من الثوره في البلد
وعندما نراقب وهذا الموضوع
نتفاجئ بكميه العنف ومدى انتشار هذه
الاعمال وبالتالي هذا سؤال مطروح في فرنسا
لا اعرف بالتحديد كيف لنا ان نشرح ذلك على
وجه الخصوص لان فرنسا هي من بين اكثر
البلدان تنظيما على المستوى السياسي
والمستوى الاداري على المستوى السياسي
لدينا مجلس شيوخ ولدينا مجلس نواب ولدينا
عمد ورؤساء
السؤال لو سمحت يعني
اللجوء دائما الى الشارع من جانب
الفرنسيين البعض قد يرى في ذلك دليل صحه
والبعض قد يرى فيه دليل عدم ثقه ربما
بالمؤسسات ما رايك انت
من الواضح والجلي وهذا ما كنت قد بدات
بقوله ان فرنسا لديها تاريخ طويل من
التعبير عن الراي ومن ناحيه اخرى هناك
هيكليات سياسيه وتنظيميه ومؤسسيه تهتم
بهذه الشؤون
تفضل نحن نسمعك
نعم نسمعك تفضل
للاسف يبدو اننا
ان صوتنا لم يعد يصل للسيد ايفا
وهو عضو مجلس شيوخ الفرنسيه السابق كان
ضيفنا من باريس وما زلنا معكم في هذه
الصور المباشر اذا هذه الصور التي حدثت
قبل قليل في بعض المدن الفرنسيه حيث تستمر
حتى هذه الساعه
التظاهرات
احتجاجا على قتل
مواطن
نائل من
اصول جزائريه بالامس على يد الشرطه
الفرنسيه
ربما عاد معنا السيد ايف
طيب اذا هذه الصور ايضا قبل قليل لاعمال
الشغب التي كانت حدثت على نطاق واسع في
هذه المدن طبعا السلطات الفرنسيه اعلنت
نشر اكثر من اربعين الف عنصر شرطه في هذه
المناطق واعلنت وقف النقل العام تحسبا
لاستمرار هذه التظاهرات يعود معنا اذا
السيد ايفوزو
سيد الان لو تحدثنا عن التظاهرات الجاريه
الان في نونتير وعدد من المدن ما هي
المخاوف لدى السلطات خصوصا وان هذه
التظاهرات تتوسع بعد التظاهرات التي كانت
شهدتها فرنسا على خلفيه رفع سن التقاعد
اذا بالنسبه الى
الاحداث نحن شاهدنا جهود الشرطه في مدن
متعدده وايضا شاهدنا ما حصل في مرسيليا
ولذلك يتعين على الحكومه ان ترد لان
الحكومه تواجه وضع ان صعبا عندما كنت انا
شابا وطالبا ومذاك لم اشهد وضعا مماثلا
اذا يبدو ان هناك بعض الاطراف التي تصر
على التصعيد وتود ان تتفادى التهدئه نامل
ان التهدئه سوف نصل اليها شكرا لك
عضو مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسيه السابق ضيفنا من
باريس مشاهدينا بهذا نصل الى نهايه حصاد
هذه